hey guys it's Chuck nice coming to you
from the start talk all-stars Studios
here in New York City and we are now
coming to you live on Facebook that's
right we're Facebook lobbing it and I
have with me yes it is Emily rice
astronomer at the American Museum of
Natural History
and summer ash and astrophysicist and
they are both the cofounders of the star
toriel list yes and that's why you guys
we're such awesome fashions it's caught
we call it Sartorialist even though
there's two of us make sure you check
out our Facebook page
yes hang in our blog Tori Ellis calm
awesome awesome so you know we just
wanted to do a little a little Facebook
live because every once in a while we
like to do this especially when we're in
the studio here where we can reach out
to the fans and just let them know first
of all everything that we do from this
studio can be seen in video form on
Startalk all-access live I mean oh
Startalk access calm okay it's Facebook
live it's star talk all-access calm
which you guys probably see me on
Wednesdays every Wednesday I come on and
I tell you what's coming up on Startalk
access calm so but right now we've got
some stuff to talk to you about that we
just want to have some fun serious very
important very very serious very
important business and everybody needs
this right now because we're talking
cats in space so I make that show okay
by the way what the hell is that with
cats in space huh two things that
everyone loves space and cats and and
it's so funny because that's all you see
is all over the Internet is cats in
space so I'm gonna look for um some
comments while you guys tell me about
this image let's get the first one up
again Ben it's burrito cat why would it
not
question why would it not be riding a
burrito in outer space food with you
when you do space travel absolutely so
but this is true by the way I don't want
to be on a spaceship with a astronaut
who's eating a burrito saying tight
spaces I'm sorry what let's talk about
what's behind that can you recognize it
I mean you guys are really good at since
that's a real thing what is that
do you know so the Carina Nebula is like
a huge star forming region that's in the
southern hemisphere it's kind of like
the southern hemisphere version of the
Orion Nebula okay that's like a one
particular like dust cloud in the
curricula it might have a I feel like it
might be called a caterpillar or
something like that I could be yeah
that's a gorgeous espouse these images
like sometimes they're ground-based
widefield images sometimes they're
Hubble Space Telescope images I think
this one might be a whole Space
Telescope image nice the colors are
beautiful on it hey check this out so uh
John John red Decker says is that a cat
paw in the background ah look at that
down the bottom I know exactly what he's
talking about it looks like a little cat
it looks like a cat paw playing like
before you play with like when they play
with a ball of string that's not it and
that's not it
hey way to go but you know just put make
like an astronomer and calls it like you
sees it that's what we do whatever it
looks like and that's the cat's paw okay
very cool nicely done been on the
come-up and here we go
all right and they don't there a lot of
people say in a cat's problem that
nebula they're all about it okay that's
know they already know let me tell you
some loser star talk these are star talk
fans they are they do not let you get
away with anything they are on point
these star talks but did they know that
they can buy clothing with the cat's paw
nebula on the clothing you can find that
at star toriel it's just a blog like we
we Hindus have some affiliate
but we're not a store we don't sell this
stuff we just find this stuff curate it
and share it with fellow astronomy
science fashion loving people all in one
place for you we did make money on hair
just said coheres just said and and now
I want a burrito
thanks look at that oh god now I am
hungry so is that a cheeto or a cheese
puffs that's a cheese puffs that's a
cheese pass the cheese puffs she knows
now makes cheese puffs no brand oh my
god you just changed my life make a
healthy version that's still pretty
cheesy cheesy it's not actually okay I
am when we leave this studio I am going
to commit me some baked Cheetos cheese
puffs something I've never had in my
life and I know my life is not complete
right now without that I'm telling you
all right so go back to the Cheetos
puffs now do you recognize anything in
this picture would that be anything that
brings a bell to you I think it could be
a real image but it's definitely
manipulated yeah it looks real to me but
the the top the top left hand and the
bottom right hand look a little bit
different and so it might actually be to
put together just to let you know star
in the top right corner if you see a
diffraction spike around the star like
the four points yeah that usually tends
to mean that it's a real image because
that's something that happens when you
you takin an image of a bright object oh
yeah and it doesn't necessarily happen
when you like say splatter paint or
something like that that's one of the
ways that you can tell a real image of
stars you know what I can't believe that
we are actually gleaning science from
this stupid segment right now because it
is the most silly thing is this most
silly thing we've ever done but yet
we're still getting science out of it
seriously this is the silliest thing
we've update you're right you're right
you're right hey by the way by the way
it's a headed cat really so I want to
know do they really put the cat's head
through the pizza no it better be for
assumes that you can buy for your own
cats that do that I think both either
one of those are
animal cruelty not if the pizza eaten
that if the cat eats his way out of the
pizza then it's not animal cruelty just
give them dinner that's all
by the way Ashley mark says summer I
love you and I think that's because your
last name has part of her first name
that's team ass way to go science is in
all forms lol and that was Rick Brown
who just said Rick didn't that moved I'm
sorry Rick you didn't say that
you said science cheeto which I love I'm
getting pizza and see those damn it I'm
doing pizza and Cheetos right after we
leave here in a burrito oh my god cheeto
all right we do we have another one Ben
do we have another that is amazing first
of all that cat is highs I don't know
what look how dilated his pupils are
alright that is amazing right there and
secondly is there any image in this
photo that could be real or you
recognize I don't recognize it but I
think you could I mean the colors
flashing different colors that's
obviously manipulated but like the
background still looks very Spacey like
nihilistic Li space it looks real look
realistically I think it's still it's
real and we're we've got me in these
images where do they come from for real
like I mean I come from I know Hubble
and NASA so when you go online
are there any ground-based amateur
images that actually make it that that
that are real do you know there's a
website Astronomy Picture of the Day
yeah APO D yeah that's run by
astronomers and a lot of times those
images that they use can be they are
taken from and made by amateur
astronomers here on earth there's a lot
of them that are like professional
amateurs there's always a credits at the
bottom and that you can link to more
information about the picture more
information about the source of the
image all that kind of stuff
great resource that is super cool is
super cool I took these pictures with my
cell phone
chase Faulkner just told us that that
picture Donner the dead cats I like that
one from Andrew Downey who who our big
zombie cat who put his face up there
yeah very cool did we mention that it
scattered a it scattered a what's up
with Caturday that we have on our blog
oh really because of the cat it's not
just the gifts you can buy clothing with
space and cats on it okay that's why not
well and I think there's even I think
there is leggings maybe that I've seen
cats and space and pizza absolutely have
cats in space and hamburgers and
cheeseburgers
oh sorry forget that I Can Has
Cheezburger
oh man I can't wait for cats and wine in
space what's up on Caturday
oh that's cool that was very cool that
one that's cat it's like Orbitz I just
lost this question I wanted to because
somebody said here you go I love that
one talking radiation coming from the
black hole
that's very cool it's purring radiation
I don't know so jess cat momentum Daniel
Schomberg says this can we please talk
about how the James Webb telescope took
20 years to build and will only have a
10-year lifespan it's not true design
lifetime for five years which is like
the standard so that's what all of them
are whether the funding from NASA and
NSF the National Science Foundation hmm
so but they think most likely it'll go
for 10 right what was the Hubble
lifetime when it was originally launched
yeah well it's probably roughly the same
but still go and it had five service
missions okay we will not be able to
service right also okay Rovers were
meant to last for 90 days and there's my
James lasted very many years yeah part
it has to it has to happen so it's for
the James Webb Space Telescope in
particular the limitation is the coolant
in fact think in space that we'd have to
actually cool down the tells me this is
already so cold
but because of the electronics and and
stuff that's always going on with the
Space Telescope and it still needs to be
even cooler in order for the infrared
electronics to work the infrared
detectors and things like that and so
we'll have coolant and that coolant will
have a temporary lifetime but usually we
build around so you know some things are
gonna stop working when the coolant runs
out but other things can keep working
even after the coolant runs out so maybe
shorter wavelength instruments or
something like that and so we always
astronomers tend not to try to over
promise but then they do over deliver I
think you'll agree I'm very cool it's
just like my life lower expectations
lower people's expectations you always
look like a star we'll be able to do
just like with Kepler when things start
functioning we find these little
workarounds right and of cool you find a
way to make it work there you go
well listen we gotta go but in the words
of who said this
Kevin doll Schrodinger would be proud
let me tell you start talked all-access
comm make sure you go check it out
because all of the things that we do on
Startalk are available on Startalk
all-access comm we actually just did the
three of us just did two shows and two
original shows that you will not be able
to see anywhere else except Startalk
all-access comm hey I'm Chuck nice you
know we love you and I got to come up
with catchphrase because I can't say
keep looking up can't freeze I need to
come up with all right so I'm Chuck nice